hey this fool yo man y'all check me out
on the bootleg kill podcast man let's
get it
yo boo lay cat podcast man special guest
in here from jacksonville
welcome man yeah yeah look hey let me
tell you something
yeah this jacksonville uh scene is um
it is going crazy yeah it's lit right
now i feel like uh
you're like one of the two or three
cities that really got this [__] going
right now i think you know obviously
memphis is going crazy
memphis but jacksonville i feel like you
know because i lived in tampa for a few
years
it always felt to me like duvall was
kind of like florida's like step child
like you know what i'm saying like as
far as the hip-hop scene you would
always hear about like miami or broward
you know what i'm saying and now i feel
like jacksonville is having this time
like you all feel like you kind of come
into the game with the with a chip on
your shoulder a little bit
no i got like a full head of stain like
i got something to prove cause i know
like
i got hard music besides like the disc
songs and
[__] like that like i got some hard [__]
so i'm just like from the pool myself
i like i got something to prove yeah
um how long have you been rapping
because i know you've been rapping for a
while but like like talk about like kind
of how you got started in the rap game
uh well
i know like two years ago i had moved to
atlanta
i had miss zatov in the studio my people
had linked me up with him right
so boom when i was in the studio i was
playing some of my songs and he was like
man you hard we need to do a mixtape
so we even we we um ended up doing six
to six tobin
and it was just up from now like i just
went up like everything when they're
going up right
right when i did um mistake with him so
but prior to that
when did you like really start like
recording like what how old were you
like what was yours
i've been rapping since i was like
probably like 12 10 i've been
rapping like in like a real studio but
it wasn't like no
gangsta route like i've been rapping
enough for like
a long time so this is something you've
been working on for a very long time
yeah yeah this ain't nothing new like
this like what i dreamed of like all my
life i knew
i was gonna be a rapper like before
anything i was gonna be a rebel yeah
cause i feel like sometimes
people fall into rap especially these
days it's something that like they never
thought that they would end up doing and
then
all of a sudden they rap and you know
what i'm saying like and for
and then there's people like yourself
who like really this is the dream the
whole time who you telling like i i
always like
i was just different like i know i ain't
want i ain't going less for myself and i
knew like i wanted to be like a
superstar like because i was always like
the
the center of attention like the class
clown like you know what i'm saying
i always wanted to intensify i knew i
was going to be a rapper
um talk about like
obviously you're you know
this is like you said the grind is is
this not you know you've been getting a
lot of notoriety lately but
but you've been around for a while yeah
if someone was watching this who
is also kind of maybe where you were
five or six years ago in your career
what would be some advice you would give
man like
like you know just coming up in the rap
game it's not an easy thing it's
probably easy to give up you know what
i'm saying
you gotta like you can't be like afraid
to take risks like
my risk was i would like because i was
so
like i love my hood the dove like you
couldn't get me to leave jacksonville
so i had like really get my ass up and
move to atlanta
and like network more because they ain't
a lot of big studios in jazz feeling
like being artists
so when i moved to atlanta i want to
meet everybody in every studio session
like
networking hard for like i'd say for
seven to six months that [__] turned me
up my followers went up i had got a blue
chat on instagram like everything just
went up like
yeah so taking that risk and moving to
atlanta was like kind of changed
everything for you
yeah yeah it was a whole nother like
environment like everything
different the way they move the way they
talk how they network
how like they show more love like don't
get me wrong it's [__] up in the
london tutorials
but of course of course they just showed
like more love it was more like open
arms than like my city type [__]
i feel like sometimes especially when
you come from like a
city that's not on the map like that
right yeah it's harder to get the love
in your hometown at first
than it is outside of your hometown you
know what i'm saying it almost is like
because these you know i feel like
like like there's no no coincidence that
most of the time when an artist
you know gets into some [__] it's at
home yeah you know what i mean because i
feel like that's where your biggest
haters are uh that's how they listen
and what what it is with me like like
just like you just said i get all the
love when i'm out of town i'm in miami
atlanta
california like i'm doing thousands of
features
interviews everything when i'm home
don't offer me no features
and interviews and club performances
none of that
like out there like you you don't feel
like i mean because i know that there's
not a lot of like
obviously there's the radio station out
there uh i forget the station's name but
the homie dr dooms out there does like
the radio guys out there show love is
there any sort of like
scene like like you know whether it's
djs or taste makers in jacksonville that
are kind of helping
you know now i ain't gonna cop
it probably just dj bigger ranking who's
a legend
yeah he probably the only one that tried
to help people
but other than that they'd be like they
don't be helping like that like is this
every man for themself and jasonville
bigger ranking is uh for people who
don't know he's a florida legend he's
pretty much yeah i mean
everybody who i know when i was living
in florida he was co-signing everybody
who was on the come up so he's a big
big influence on the johnsonville music
scene um
before you know like when you were
growing up what was the jacksonville
music scene
like what was the scene like what were
the like were there names that were like
ringing off in the city when you were a
kid
you know maybe they didn't necessarily
make it big time like what were the
like what was that scene like before you
kind of got deep into it you probably
know trapped back when you're on track
yeah
for the birthday cheer you had him chad
beckham's from jacksonville i don't know
why i thought he was from tampa yeah
he's from
he from jacksonville you had him he done
got plenty got plaques
tokyo she always she was like one of the
first one of the first artists two that
blew up it was just really like them to
to to i wave kane and then osiris
you know on the r b sign yeah that's
that's our way though i grew up with
those songs
i mean yeah he's a kid yeah but he he
was in our way
and his dad i meant his pops his
popsicles used to be a rapper
yeah yeah that's why he was rooting so
hard for outsiders yeah i remember i met
i met his dad and i was like hey i
didn't even know he was from
jacksonville yeah i said y'all from
florida right
he's like why are you saying that i'm
like y'all look like some florida ass
[__]
oh bro for a show for sure how much
influence did like uh kodak
in in his movement in like 2014
2013-15 like that era of kodak's career
how much did that influence jacksonville
because because for people who don't
know like
geography like the top of jack really
yeah the top of florida
right is jacksonville a lot of people
call it south uh south georgia
because it's right there on it's like
right there but like did kodak influence
y'all like because i feel like kodak has
so much influence in florida in general
especially with the younger generation
but i said we caught more to like the
chicago
detroit like man west way because when
you go down south that's really florida
like florida florida like
there's some other florida [__] yeah
yeah it's [__] you ain't gonna hear no
killing music you're gonna have some
fast music but you come on no the jazz
if you're gonna hear some straight
killing [__] like that's all that's what
you have to realize like
yeah it's crazy because even like
central florida they got their own
like in tampa they got jerk [__] i don't
know if you've heard that have you i
don't know if you've done the tampa wave
yet but they got their own [__] it's
like
i've never heard when i lived there yeah
tom g
crystal all these guys make music that
are
lit as [__] in that city and it's like
bro
it's a sonically like some [__] that you
went out here anywhere else it's crazy
florida's like his own country
like it's like his own continent yeah
it's like every every part of it has got
his own culture his own sound
and while i say you could go well from
the jacksonville you'll hear something
different you go down south you hear
like you know what i'm saying
you go to pensacola where they sounded
like they're from alabama
you know what i'm saying from
tallahassee t-pain from tyler house and
[__] like that people won't even know
that though yeah
um you mentioned you said in
jacksonville you
you you you described the type of music
in jacksonville as op killing music
uh yeah that's what they own right now
they on straight
block spinning bending music that's all
they want to hear that's what it is
i've heard a lot of people compare
what's going on in your city right now
to
being the new chicago as far as just the
violence and
a lot of the negativity that's coming
out of jacksonville yeah um
we'll get to like you know your
situation and how you might be
mixed up in some of that but just in
general why do you why do you feel like
that's the energy right now in
jacksonville
because the way like the news portraying
it you got the real
news people portraying it a certain way
then you got the killings you got the
multiple mass shootings like we we
number one for mass shooting that mean
three people getting ahead of time two
or three people never know one person
getting hit you got it
people looking at that then you got a
rap that come and play
it's going viral in the industry none
then like everybody got a name so
everybody gotta say so like it is a lot
it's just like oh no it's just a lot
are you are you signed to anyone or are
you indie like what is your situation
oh i'm locked in with creative user
right now so so they do distribution
obviously
shout out to create they distribute a
lot of artists yeah they also distribute
six nine for people who don't know
that's
yeah they do that for them yeah um
do you feel because you know kind of
watching what's going on
uh you know i saw the uh
obviously the video that went viral that
you replied to
yeah you know and i've met ace i haven't
met the other two guys
yeah but when i met ace um it might have
been
four or five months after he got shot so
i interviewed him and he seemed like a
sweet dude you know what i'm saying
yeah um you know
i saw that video and i was like yo this
is
this is a high level of disrespect here
obviously yeah
um song bang you know what i'm saying
but
when you saw it like what was your
initial reaction when you saw that thing
uh i really wouldn't i
ain't gonna i really wasn't mad i was
just like on some more
just because i do the same thing you
know i'm saying i
like you know i said i've been making
this songs and like [__] like that so
i know how they be feeling but i went i
i really went like
too much press i was more of mad like uh
like certain people like that was saying
in that part with my dad brothers names
no name i really went mad at the song
itself i don't know you were just mad at
that part
yo my brother's name my dad by the name
of it like it's a good song
so yeah i mean i think that the other
thing that's probably gonna be weird is
the fact that like that part you're
talking about
is also a part that's like became a meme
yeah
so like you might see somebody replace
you know i've seen some basketball ones
you know what i'm saying where it'll be
like a basketball player will pop in you
know
but but it's that's that's got to be
kind of
like that [__] it's when something goes
viral like that it's almost like [__]
that's what it is right now and then you
know those people got families and like
you said those
you know that's your fam you know what
i'm saying definitely um
what exactly you know when i when i was
coming up listening to hip-hop i felt
like there was
there was like lines that a lot of
people didn't cross now tupac and biggie
you know podcat hit him up which
which was a pretty pretty scathing
record but um
i know a lot of people have passed in
your situation
but where's the line man because i feel
like there is no line and these these
like
like the records you put out with with
you know being at the gravesite and all
that [__]
that's a that's like is there a is that
is that something you think you might
regret one day man because i feel like
you know that's a real
death is a real sacred thing yeah and i
feel like uh
you know unfortunately it just feels
like it's it between both of these songs
and this beef it just feels like it's
it's
there's just zero lines like
everything's been crossed like it's
um oh i ain't gonna see
it's a well i ain't going to be honest
ain't no line like [__] like am i
sitting
nobody don't go [__] on bro like
everybody straight
on goal like 24 7 something like ain't
no line they just keep getting
escalated and up oh oh well you know
what i'm saying
that's just how it is are you worried
like because my thing is is like
i feel like the kind of energy y'all
playing with like
it's more people end up dead man you
know what i'm saying
it's it's it's we've we've lost so many
people in music you know you've lost so
many of your friends
yeah when is like to you when is like
enough enough oh
[__] i say
hmm
really is not nor enough cause it is
it's just a straight playing field ain't
no rules in the street so
people doing whatever to get at people
either way whether it's
songs catching a [__] with his wife
whatever [__] doing whatever to catch
[__] what happened to you right your
girl got shot is
that why car got shut up your car got
shine your girl was in the car right
yeah i went in the car she was driving
did she get hit yeah but she good though
she's like again
seeing my girl she might as well but
again right like
that's something that under normal
circumstances you would think is
like i you know what i'm saying off
limits if that makes sense yeah
but it seems like what with what was
whatever's going on
in jacksonville [__] is really really
there's no like i said there's just no
lines and and i don't know if there's
something to i don't know man i just i
just i would hate to open my phone
and see your name on academics and be
like you know
or see even see aces name you know what
i'm saying like the end of the day both
y'all came out the same city
both of you guys are are making money
off this rap [__] you know what i'm
saying
i just i don't i just i would i don't
know if there's i mean i don't
understand when people lose their life
it's
it's really no like there's nothing else
to be talked about but at the same time
like you would hope there would be some
sort of resolution
to stop any sort of future you know
situations that might put you in harm or
or anybody else in harm
definitely yeah yeah oh no though man is
this [__] it's just
screeches you know oh no i couldn't even
tell you was
a solution another it just scratched it
when you when you put out um
when i see you um did you have any
hesitation about putting that out or
shooting the video that way
no i don't know it's just [__]
i ain't gonna count when i uploaded the
preview that she had a million views on
my [__]
on my instagram so when i was going
through the comments they were like
um it was like a whole bunch of
suggestions they said i do
kind of montana party in the usa they
were saying all kind of crazy [__] on
bro
but what stuck out to me the most was on
the fantasia [__] and a lot of other
artists was calling me telling me to do
that [__]
you know what i'm saying so i went to
the studio i had told the internet to
pull up the beat
that and i made like the um i punched in
on the chorus first i ain't even go
straight into the verse i went straight
to the chorus like
because i already had it in my mind what
i wanted to say so yeah when i did that
and i like finished the song i would do
the bible tie
i swear to god so i say this [__] and go
bar
i just left the studio after that got a
song about it do you find yourself um
like moving around like like i mean
obviously you're out here in l.a you
know what i'm saying
yeah but i can only assume like
you have to be somewhat paranoid to be
around certain parts like not not saying
like you're scared
but you always got to be on your toes
low-key with the kind of [__] you
[__] with you know what i'm saying
like
yeah yeah i'm like tight and then she's
so crazy bro
like just go back to when you were in
other cities they show you love but i
came out here
and there's no cap so many gamers
reached out to me bro
like on some old i ain't gonna say the
gang name they bought me like you know
what i'm saying some polls and [__] like
you good here bro like protect yourself
just bring that [__] back when you leave
tight [__]
you know i'm saying people got respect
for me in the screech like you know what
i'm saying
and i fought with [__] like and i'm
real dear tied in you know what i'm
saying so
it is the way i little like i know the
like consequences of how i'm living so
i don't know you're at peace with that
yeah
cause it's like this the way i'm living
like i gotta you gotta accept the
consequence like
even when i was born bro even though i
know what i was getting myself
into i had a chance to change my life
plenty of time when i was younger but it
was just like this is what it was like
that's how i want to live i'm saying
would could anything ever happen to get
you and ace to sit across the table from
each other and
have a discussion i don't know sure but
just just just you know something that's
not like a
you know person put everything on the
table and try to move past it is that
something that you think could ever even
happen
um to be honest
i couldn't answer that question i really
don't know
honey i don't know i don't know
because he's younger than you right no
he's older than me oh he's older than
you oh [__] i didn't because i
remember i saw something on on youtube
you were saying that like back in the
day like like uh
when you was rapping yeah cass was in
your videos
yeah they used to be well not ace crew
but the other people on the song though
my videos yeah they used to be in my
videos shaking the eyes
yeah man i just you know i can't have
you come on here and not try to you know
be like hey look bro like
i don't want to see anybody pass away
bro i'm already known though like you
know what i'm saying
i'm knowing what it is every time i open
my [__] phone every week i feel
like it's some other rapper
you know uh dying bro and i you know i
think that um
i'm not gonna lie man coming from like
an older generation
the [__] is low-key like i like
disturbing to me when i see this [__]
and the other thing that i really gotta
like you know
the whoever is whether it's whoever ace
assigned to
or whoever you're working with like i
feel like
there's more that obviously this record
is huge for you right is this
was this was this record probably the
most viral moment you've had
i've been at like 7 million in a week
and it's almost like
yo the more negativity and [__] that
transpires the more money gets
brought in and that's a crazy two to me
it's like
okay boom before this song right here
right
i draw a beat box with my cousin kojak
like i said i had like 460 followers i'm
at like
641 43 k9 some [__] off of just
like nothing show prices i'm booked up
nah
i'm like money going off listen beef is
always good for business but it's not
it's not good
for your life yeah for your life yeah
because what if you know you mentioned
that your you know your car got shot and
your ex got hit what if you know i don't
know if you have any children or not
no but you know that's good but like
imagine maybe you know somebody else
that's close to you was in that car or
maybe you know she would have got hit
and passed away i just
you know what i'm saying i'm just trying
to bring some reason to the table
because i just feel like you know
everyone's from the same city everyone's
getting money
it seems like jacksonville i've never
seen
uh so much division in a in a region
that's like
it's crazy even like because the spot
him got him kids from there right
yeah he from like one one of the hood
did he from right here from dirt world
that's like a hood that we fought with
in jacksonville yeah even like you know
people got problems with him you know i
mean those you know the snitching
allegations all that [__] like
i just feel like [__] for a city that's
fresh to
you know being like the it city in
hip-hop
no one's really moving together i know
you got short but it just feels like
man that [__] is crazy bro like are you
telling it is though
i was thinking one day though like when
i was in the car i'm like damn
imagine if all of us were just together
on small city [__] and if y'all
were together imagine how crazy it would
be it should be crazy
like if you think to like back in the
day like when the way miami was moving
together when it was ross and trina and
trick like everybody was a movement it
was
powerful you couldn't stop it you know
even in new york in l.a
like right now in la all the young kids
in la are all moving together
like in the same direction you know what
i'm saying older generations you
probably couldn't say that for but
i just you know yeah if y'all all
somehow figured a way to just
and and again i'm not here to tell you
that that's possible because you
there has been people's lives lost yeah
so when that happens
i can't tell you how to react or how to
deal with that pain period you know what
i'm saying or maybe
but i just know that like more
you know more bloodshed it's not gonna
you're not gonna get not gonna be at
peace with that man
you know what i'm saying it might feel
it might feel that way but
it's it's just you know 20 30 years from
now you know
if you make it god bless you know what
i'm saying what is um
what's next for you music wise because
this record is obviously going crazy
it's a diss record but like as far as
just
you know working on an album i'm like
you said i'm sure hella
new artists are reaching out to you
everybody i ain't gonna even lie
to you bro i don't have probably like
any rapper you could think of in my damn
bro
any label you could think of like being
damning me like right now
but i got two mistakes from the drop my
deluxe and i'm going to drop another
mixtape right after that
my deluxe already done but i'm just
waiting on like one more feature to come
back i got so many features right now
too like
everybody just reaching out who you got
records with right now uh
i got some [__] with fredo bang great
guy
uh me and sparta obviously
i'm gonna have hot boy you know how well
of course shout out to orlando
uh orlando too another city is kind of
wild right now
yeah shout out to central florida ciao
pootie's on there i'm gonna [__] we're
probably gonna drop some new [__] too we
gotta get some new [__] into it yo
have to stop the bootleg podcast real
quick and shout out our sponsor odd
socks
that's right they've been holding us
down from the jump man and they're
not only the makers of the most
comfortable socks in the world shout out
to odd socks
but they also now got the draws man
the boxer briefs are so fire they're so
soft
they feel great on your ass your nuts
whatever you're into
you know what i'm saying whatever you
got they'll cover them up real real
comfortably
and ladies you know you could wear these
things to sleep so go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use the keyword bootleg kev save 20 off
you know
one of the licenses they just got that i
love are the naruto socks they just got
the naruto socks
of course they got wwe those are mankind
socks ladies and gentlemen
spongebob and shout out to the the goat
ric flair so what you got to do get you
some odd socks
thank me later save 20 off at checkout
by using the keyword bootleg
kev at oddssocksoficial.com and we are
super proud that they're presenting this
podcast let's get back to it
yeah i got so many songs right now bro
yeah yeah
are you um are you still in jacksonville
are you used to in atlanta like all
right i stand alone
i move my mama i got her house in the
london i stand on the tutor
yeah i was i was talking to uh to young
blue and uh
you know he's from uh alabama but yeah
out here right now i just saw that
a little bit like yesterday two days ago
smart smart dude man but
he lives in mississippi yeah he's like i
got the [__] out the way got to
you can't stand your city for long and
be successful i get harassed by the
police down there
every day i step outside like when i'm
down i heard i've heard that
about like specifically that
jacksonville police are like the worst
oh yeah they not they they beat your ass
all type of [__] they killed my brother
kendrick i got a wristband all right
i always keep the wristband on people
who watching the interview too they
asked me why you got that blue wristband
on this mother brother kendrick who died
by the police yeah when how long ago was
that um he was like 16 to 15. that was
in 2015 though
[__] yeah he didn't even have no gun on
them or nothing like they
know that's crazy i feel like that's
happening so much it's like
that should be good yeah jacksonville
i've heard that the cops there are like
amongst like some of the worst
to deal with yes
uh when you were like coming up um
was because when you was i'm trying to
think if the jaguars were good when you
was
younger they were good like when mark
brennell was the
old matter of fact they was good that
one year with jayla around a few years
ago when they
made the afc championship game but now
you got trevor lawrence's on
your number one pick you know what i'm
saying like are you pretty like like are
you a football fan
are you tapped in yeah but i will
they'll put my faith in their job wash
they let us down every year bro like any
time bro like they let us down
every year bro you know so i don't
really put my faith in the jaguars
like that that's fair what about like
outside of
enjoying football what are what are the
things that you you enjoy outside of you
know
rapping and and uh what are you doing
your free time man
i just be taking trips sometimes but i
ain't gonna count
i'd really be tuned into music like
that's like what helped me escape
like the studio that's what really what
i'd be on only thing i want to do is be
in the studio somewhere just
hearing my voice do like a pain beat or
something like that like that help me
event
and i just chill is it like kind of like
a therapy you think yeah something like
that yeah matter of fact exactly like
therapy like it helped me event
like you know yeah i feel like nowadays
you know
it's been a little um more acceptable to
you know say you you need some therapy
you need some sort of outlet to deal
with you know i'm sure you got
all the [__] you've been through you
definitely got some [__] you know
to talk about to talk about and the [__]
and you have you ever considered going
to scene like an actual therapist
yeah bro oh my god oh my love brother i
want a better grade completely didn't
ask me that yesterday bro
oh did they yeah yeah bernardo i'm good
well
you know you know what i'm saying i
can't handle myself but you know it is
what it is
that [__] crazy sad though yeah maybe i
might need to go see a therapist
hey man you never know bro like honestly
it's really not even like you can't even
look at it like there's something wrong
with you you got to look at it like yo
sometimes you just need someone to talk
to that's not a part of your situation
that's not in your world to give you a
different perspective on life you know
what i'm saying
facts um have you noticed
like people switching up around you the
bigger you're getting
people coming out the woodworks people
hitting you for money you know what i'm
saying
that [__] be daily bro like i ain't
gonna say no name but i go through that
[__]
daily bro like and it's getting to the
point i'd be like damn i wish i would
never became a rapper like damn i wish i
what if i wasn't successful you wouldn't
be calling me you wouldn't be trying to
be for me made this song about me when
you could call my phone
you know what i'm saying like [__] it's
like people i never thought would switch
on me just change
every day and that's it how you just
thinking bro does that [__] happen with
like rappers in your city where you
thought you were cool with someone but
it might be a good look for them to try
to say some [__] about you because it
helps kind of boost their [__]
man that's man i know this is this is
going on bro
all right [__] you you think you love
for like
and ain't that for real like once you
get to a certain level in life [__]
looking at you like damn
you pulled to do syz but where you was
when i was like
po and where you was why you ain't with
me right now when i offered this [__]
like come with me hit the road with me
you know what i'm saying
you ain't gotta pay for [__] right now
i'm saying hit the road me grind it out
with me you want to be a rapper too come
on come around with me do what i did you
know what i'm saying
cause i ain't nobody i ain't never had
no og i know all the person saying
humble little
take this bag of money uh go do that you
know what i'm saying i did it myself bro
work ethic man i'm saying i had to cry
for this [__] so i feel like if you want
that [__] you got to cry for that [__]
too
yeah man show me you want that [__] no
is that that work ethic is missing man
with a lot of these kids bro who you
telling
and uh i feel like that's kind of what
separates
the good from the greats is that is that
work ethic that willingness to eat [__]
for
the beginning of your career and go stay
in the super eight motel in whatever
random city you might
go grab a little bag at you know what
i'm saying and i come back to sacrifice
you got to sacrifice [__] bro
you know what i'm saying sacrifice
anything that's worth worth having you
got to sacrifice got it bro and i swear
once you sacrifice that [__]
it's gonna work out bro i promise bro
like that [__] be god telling you to do
the [__] you supposed to go through this
[__] but it's just like a test like
if you don't you're gonna be stuck in
the same it's common sense bro if you
don't do it you're gonna be stuck in the
same spot if you do you're gonna elevate
it
you know what i'm saying you gotta go
get it you can't sit on your ass yeah
man
like what what what's kind of the
biggest sacrifice you think you've made
um to to kind of get where you are
when i first moved to atlanta like my
very first when i had the apartment
though not the house when i had the
apartment
and i said when i was in jacksonville i
went down like that
all this [__] going on around me this
and that all these labels calling
[__] dying every [__] other day and
[__]
i just need to get away from this [__] i
need to be in better environment for me
to record
link up with new artists and [__] so i'm
like [__] this [__]
i need an apartment in london i went to
london that's how that shot
yeah i think um i mean [__] is paying
off for you
i mean you say the deluxe is coming
mm-hmm and
you already got another mixtape coming
as well two minute states
so you gonna flood the rest of the year
yeah i'm from the flood like i don't
think i just showed them like i'm not
just no like
this rapper obviously people know i'm
not that's the song i brought right now
that's what's blowing me up right now in
the industry like that's what just got
my foot in the door
a diss on the [__] you know what i'm
saying that should be crazy well hey was
there any um
when you saw gucci and jeezy bury the
hatchet at their verses
uh did that what what did you think of
that because i think that that that was
something that
a lot of people were critical of you
know personally my my
opinion was it's a great example to show
people they can move past some crazy
[__] you know what i'm saying
yeah i see like that's that's that's
that's
i say they both grown
i think both of them got kids and [__]
so they handled it
like man you know what i'm saying
jeezy how did it like how he was
supposed to because
i ain't gonna lie i'm still young
he couldn't perform that song in my face
it's just out of respect though like
you don't who killed my homeboy you made
a rap about it any performing in my face
after we talked about squashing the [__]
after we doing this hell nah
something would have had to happen but
no i do i like the way they did that
though they came together
squash that [__] and they rock i just
think like at the end of the day like
to be beefing with someone when you're
40 still that's it 45
it's like yo man like you grown like you
said you don't have any kids you know
what i'm saying like
yeah the other thing i wanted to talk to
you about is like
just to try to just you know plant
something in your head is i noticed that
you know nowadays unfortunately you know
you know my dog you know shout out to
casanova he's locked up right now
okay um but a lot of
if the authorities are using lyrics and
and music against people
in cases and stuff you know are you
i mean is that something you think about
when you put out your music like i'm not
saying you've ever said anything that's
oh but it's like but some of the [__]
that's in these records i'm like
i don't listen to the majority of every
song and how
i don't look into every case like i look
at that [__] for real like
okay boom not even me you're a rapper
right
you're rapping by guns you hot your ass
in the car you ride with guns you get
pulled over that just you're a product
of your environment
so with me i'm from the house of kitty
with me you know something more smart
i often have somebody that got a they
registered
what i'm saying i ain't gonna go crash
out if you know like
you know i'm saying what you doing out
here you doing wrong you should protect
yourself bro like the way you don't have
to just go crash out cause
i'm at the point of my career bro i got
a lot to lose right now bro like 100
i don't i don't got time to be sitting
in no sale you know great
mama depending on me to pay bills and
i'll type all this [__] you know what
i'm saying so i ain't going to do no
out off the wall dumb [__] you know what
i'm saying i'm past that no not
the old me the 2015 yeah yeah let's do
this
like right let's go rock eye but no i
mean chilling
you know what i'm saying well listen man
you seem like a real smart dude and i
feel like you know
you got a bright future ahead of you i
just i just you know for
for what it's worth man if i let me be
the old head
yeah yeah i'm [__] with you bro try
to you know talk some senses here
what are you doing like you know you
meant you know you're making a lot of
money you doing anything with money you
know as far as investing you know
opening businesses crypto
and that's your own bro like i need
because i got money like i don't be
knowing what they're investing
but i heard about some [__] about the
stocks and [__] but i don't really know
how that [__] worked but then again
i was thinking about like getting like
corner stoves and like property like
land and [__] anything's better than
cash
who you telling because all that cash
man is first of all
it's it's depreciating it's not making
you no money and everything from the
turn digital
no no 100 percent yeah bitcoin get that
bitcoin
the dollar bill like give it a couple
years you don't use no 20
bills anywhere you go they ask for card
now bro i haven't really liked it
it's hard to pay for cash like if you
like some places just won't accept your
money now we don't take cash like what
do you mean you don't take cash
from rental cars to hotels you got to
have a deposit on the car we need your
car
on 500 man and that's cause this why
because money not traceable cars and all
that [__] is you know what i'm saying
it's deeper than that yeah you're right
no no you're right i'm wondering um
coming out of jacksonville who who's
like your top five all-time rappers not
not from the city just overall who
influenced you who was
like who's your all-time five uh
i gotta say lil wayne i used to listen
to him
meek mill um
let me see soldier slim r.i.p
trade drake for show i put a sound first
i fought drake hard
uh one more uh
i'm just keep with that foe i like that
four soldier slim drake
wayne meek that's not a bad anybody from
chicago
uh who i thought were from chicago
rp the young papa i was [__] his [__]
hard
um of course chief keith how how like
how how how big of a
i mean i feel like chief keef you know
like it love it hated whatever he's one
of the most influential rappers of all
time
yes he he he had an effect
i feel like on everybody across the
united states like if you was a young
person coming up
and because you got you got to think
about like this 2 thousands babies they
ain't grow up to the old school music
right [__] like they grew up the keefe
yeah and like kodak and [__] like that
so they ain't that's all they know
is gang gang druid that's all they know
because that's what's getting put out
but hell yeah
he keep had an impact on the world
though if you could get a feature from
anybody it'd have to be the drake
feature though
right yeah yeah that's just out of here
that's right for
dre says god shout out to drake and
shout out to you man uh
when's the lux dropping uh i don't even
got no date but they waiting on me to
get on my date [__] i'm trying to see
right now though [__]
but listen man be careful out here um
and hopefully you know
there's no more disc records
there it is man hey fulio thank you for
pulling up